quelle a été la meilleure équipe du
canadien de montréal en 1986 le gardien
patrick roy réalise des arrêts
spectaculaires et son équipe remporte la
coupe stanley en 1993
l'attaquant vincent damphousse récolte
97 points en saison régulière une autre
coupe stanley en 2014
le gardien kari presse même le canadien
en finale de l'est le tricolore a plus
de 100 ans
choisir la meilleure équipe de tous les
temps demeure subjectif mais on s'assume
à radio canada on a décidé après un long
débat que l'équipe 1976 1977 a été la
meilleure de tous les temps
pourquoi d'abord l'équipe était formée
des plus grandes légendes guy lafleur et
steve shot à l'attack guy lapointe à la
défense ken dryden devant le filet et
scotty bowman comme entraîneur ensuite
l'équipe 1976 1977 et détentrice de
nombreux records une saison de 132
points 60 victoires contre huit défaites
bref une année exceptionnelle qui a même
permis à la formation de remporter la
coupe stanley vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec notre choix alors prouver nos qu'on
a tort